I'm the chairman of Lloyd's and over
these grates join everybody I've been
asked if I express my view on this
question of worldly world economy
turnout in 2009 I've always been an
optimist and would love to answer yes
and I think the realist in me says it's
going to take a while and unfortunately
we've got these people jump layoffs
being announced that all over the world
of a lot of very hardworking people at
least when I jokes it puts everyone who
does they're going to have a long
distance and on other things which made
the other people want to have the job
security somehow this is all to be king
started and I'm confident it'll happen
but much I'd love to say it's going to
be fixed by the end of this year I don't
think so so I am optimistic that the
woman worked very hard to try and get
this right as soon as we can and maybe
if we're standing here next year I will
be improved wrong which would be great
or at least we'll be on the way liner
very much torture